in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Adam and Jennifer with us hey guys how
are you good where are you guys from
we're from Muscle Shoals Alabama well
welcome to the show and thanks for
visiting us here in Nashville so you're
here to do your debt-free scream yes I
love it and how much have you paid off
we put up two hundred thousand dollars
awesome and how long did that take about
two and a half years way to go making
what kind of money about 135 combined
income excellent what do you guys do for
a living
we're both veterinarians very cool good
gig very good
so I'm guessing with that that the
student loans might have been part of
the 200k it was all in the middle so how
long have you all been married there's a
correlation here okay so you got married
got out of school got the jobs and got
in attack mode
yep off to the races okay so the first
time you got out you got married and and
you said I look down the way okay we got
to deal with this mess and we're making
good money so we got to knock it out
yeah yeah we pretty much you know
graduated in May and um and then got
married in July and you know there are a
lot of a lot of different plans out
there you know but they were all kind of
want you to you know hold on to it for
25 years and even the best plans out
there the money you know were 10 years
and we were just didn't want this
hanging around for that long well you
you got after it I mean I'm not a grand
a year almost yeah out of 135 you were
and you've had to pay taxes so you were
living on beans and rice yeah really it
was peanut butter and jelly well there's
all kinds of broke people food but you
were making over 100k and living on
broke people food sure yeah well you
know tell me how you did this in terms
of the emotions of it because I mean vet
school that's as tough as med school
sure I mean a lot of people don't know
that it's actually one of my friends
it's a veterinary and says it's actually
harder than med school because med
school you only have to learn one
species sure you know you guys you've
been in school a long time yeah yeah
we've been you had to avoid that
temptation to come out and go I finally
and making some money and instead you
went straight to this and knocked it out
how what made you do that well we really
just
want this hanging over our heads for a
long time and so we knew if we
sacrificed right now then it would pay
off in the long run and so we really
just kept a small lifestyle and a small
lifestyle and just you know attacked it
it's got after it yeah I mean you know
there was a lot of you know a lot of
things going on that you know we wanted
to do we want you know we wanted to
travel we wanted to go see UT football
you know there was a had a couple
opportunities to do that with some
friends and we just said that you know I
had to say you don't know if not this
year we've got bigger plans and and just
just hold off and really be content and
what God's given us and and that was
huge you know just just being being
content and and it's just just really
looking forward and being blessed and
knowing that he's given us given us
everything and now and for us to use
that to you know the wrong way is not
what you want so so you met in vet
school vet school and where'd y'all go
to vet school
Tennessee hey you take it alright and
that's the football reference okay cool
cool
and so you're engaged you're heading
towards graduation heading towards the
wedding and you're talking about this I
had a time oh yeah I mean we pretty much
you know going and we started dating
second year in vet school and we knew we
had loans you know that was just kind of
the normal thing but when we got down to
it we got engaged in December before
graduation and we just kind of said you
know we're pretty much split right down
the middle here if we you know and and
like I said that was at first you know
she was I had read your book right after
graduation and I'd been listening to
podcast and read your book this is we
weren't married yet but I gave it to her
and I said you know read it let me know
what you think she read it and and once
once she read it she was we fired up and
just you know we thought that you know
maybe get it done in seven years five
years and then we got going and we're
like no I think we can do it quicker
than that
so yeah you leaned in I mean you got you
got some momentum and took off very cool
yes so guys I wanted to ask you a
question you know you've ever thought
about what that $200,000 how much
interest
would have accumulated if you would have
paid it like most folks do over like
10-15 years
yeah that's crazy even what we paid
about 15,000 of it was already
interesting that was just over four
years in school in the two and a half
years yeah I suppose gonna ask you that
right so 135 thousand dollars a year and
now you don't have this payment you've
been living on peanut butter and jelly
where does your lifestyle go now are you
going all the way up to 135 we've got
those you know we want to save up for a
down payment on a house yeah and just
really you know really we just want we
want to give you want to give back
because you know we've been blessed with
far more than we need yeah
and so there's no way we need $135,000
to live on and so if we can give a large
percentage of that we're going to well
national averages your all's income is
probably going to double in the next few
years
we're excited that possibility the
people that we can that we can teach and
and the good work that we can do for God
with this you know with this what we've
been blessed with and that's what we're
excited about Financial Peace University
about a year into it
and one thing that really hit me was
when you said in the videos you know
imagine what the people of God could do
for the kingdom of God if they arrived
at and if we don't have payments to make
to banks into the government then we can
give all of that to to God and his
kingdom absolutely well and and the you
know the probability you completely
changing your family tree is very high
right now I mean you guys are incredible
you're very disciplined you and you're
on the same team and your game plan is
huge amount I would say that's one of
the biggest things is you know not been
on the same team but it would be almost
impossible to do this you know if your
spouse isn't on the same team if you
don't you know then you just kind of
people made fun of you well we a lot of
people maybe not understand exactly
watching your eyes or people's faces
went right before your mind your sweet
people tell us like well that's great
for you but I could never do that you're
so weird what they're saying yeah but we
wanted to go in here and tell everybody
that utility can do it there's nothing
special about us nothing special about
the principles here it's just you live
on less than you make and you're able to
power that and we listen to that free
screams pretty much every day Jennifer
for president so we just wanna be
encouragement to people that are either
going through right now or they are
thinking about it that it's totally
doable if you just sacrifice and get it
out of the way then you've got the whole
rest of your life ahead of you
y'all are special you're you're
incredible folks I'm so proud of you
thank you thank you so much very cool go
Vols to $200,000 paid on Adam and
Jennifer Muscle Shoals Alabama two and a
half years it took them making 135 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
are you ready 3 2
I love it absolutely awesome hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you are
not a victim you're not a victim of big
corporations you're not a victim of Wall
Street you're not a victim of capitalism
you're not a victim of wealth inequality
you're not a victim of racism you're not
a victim